en los años 70 justamente cuando termina
su paso por el Santos y Él llega al
contrato con el cosmos de Nueva York
recordemos que en ese momento no existía
lo que hoy es que es la mls hasta ahora
Estados Unidos estaba empezando como a
entender un poco ese deporte de masas
pero a los directivos de Estados Unidos
le llamaba la atención especialmente lo
que fue los tres mundiales de la década
de los 70 primeros en ser televisados a
nivel global porque tal vez el primer
mundial televisado que fue el de
Inglaterra 66 se vio en ciertos países
principalmente el Reino Unido pero
después de México 70 y especialmente
después de las olimpiadas de México en
el 68 se empezó a masificar las
transmisiones de televisión en el mundo
y pues obviamente Estados Unidos y su
industria de entretenimiento siempre
estuvieron de la mano con el cine el
radio y la televisión observando
aquellos fenómenos masivos y a ellos les
llamó mucho la atención que el fútbol
fuera tan importante en otros países y
no fuera importante en la propia nación
Así que comenzaron creando un un equipo
digamos que donde no solo era pelea
había otras Estrellas de la época el
cosmos empezó a presentarse en en
partidos amistosos a nivel mundial
tratando de copiar un poco lo que ya
venía haciendo el Santos desde los años
60 que era ir por todo el mundo a hacer
partidos amistosos de extinción que eran
cobrados a una tarifa aproximada de 25
mil dólares por partido de la época
entonces claro no es lo mismo ir a jugar
un equipo cualquiera que ir a jugar con
Pelé tres veces campeón del mundo el
mejor jugador digamos de este siglo
pasado entonces Cosmos empezó a tratar
de hacer ese mercadeo y años después ese
inicio que fue de un equipo que fue el
cosmos terminó derivando en una serie
oferta de la federación internacional
de Estados Unidos Perdón la federación
de Estados Unidos a la FIFA de que ellos
querían organizar el primer mundial en
los años 90 para poder a partir de ahí
crecer la mls que es lo que
efectivamente ha venido sucediendo tal
vez la única cosa que ellos no
calcularon es que su fútbol se volvió
mucho más exitoso a nivel femenino que a
nivel masculino de una manera muy rápida
y hoy podemos hablar de que Estados
Unidos es una potencia femenino y en
masculino pues lo vimos en su real
dimensión en el mundial de Qatar que
llegó hasta los octavos de final y en
algunas ocasiones ha participado en
mundiales con cierto nivel de éxito pero
a un nivel todavía muy preliminar y la
misma MLS Todavía está en construcción
en ese sentido Pelé fue la piedra que
inició esa gran construcción que todavía
falta para que el fútbol de Norteamérica
siga creciendo Y por eso vamos a tener
en pro de tres años y medio un mundial
allá nuevamente ellos siguen interesados
en el deporte Rey siguen interesados en
las transmisiones ahora ya no solo por
televisión sino por redes por
plataformas seguramente esa va a ser la
gran pelea de aquí en adelante ya no
serán solo los derechos de televisión
sino los derechos de retransmisión en
otras tecnologías que de pronto ni
siquiera conocemos en este momento Belén
Entonces se volvió como un símbolo Y
adicionalmente tuvo
en su extensa vía de exjugador contratos
con compañías importantes como
mastercard que lo que trataban era de
validarse a través de Pelé Pelé fue
embajador de mastercard y hizo muchas
campañas de responsabilidad social en
diferentes países y hoy todavía vemos a
mastercard patrocinando algunos temas
del fútbol a nivel internacional pero en
la gran figura que ellos tuvieron en su
momento para masificar también un
producto que era difícil en algunas
latitudes Pues fue utilizar la imagen de
Pelé y hay que recordar también que él
participó en muchos debates en muchas
conferencias digamos plataformas
académicas donde lo llevaban como a ver
qué podía opinarse en ciertos países
para mejorar el fútbol o qué cosas
podían hacerse para que el fútbol fuera
más fácil para la gente de bajos
recursos continentes de pronto no con
tanto dinero como nos pasa en América
Latina áfrica o Asia porque pues como
usted dice el fútbol en Europa digamos
concentra el recurso grande Pelé de
alguna manera fue una forma de mostrar
que ese talento y fíjense que hoy
todavía existe viene es de países de
Sudamérica acabamos de ganar el mundial
como Sudamérica con Argentina
y la idea es que los europeos Se
volvieron importadores del talento
suramericano Pero obviamente aprendieron
de él con figuras muchos años después ya
que estamos hablando que el primer
importante brasilero que llegó al fútbol
italiano fue después de la década del
setenta fue cinco participó en los
mundiales de España y México 86 chico
fue el primero que llegó allá audine y
fue como Oiga se puede traer jugadores
de Suramérica a Europa Ya empezaron
después las grandes contrataciones que
pues obviamente hoy ya van desbordadas O
sea que sí fue una leyenda fue una
figura utilizada para
masificar promocionar y utilizar también
un mensaje de que en el fútbol también
hay que tener una parte importante de
responsabilidad social porque lo que sí
hizo Pelé fue a lo largo de toda su
historia cuidar su imagen a diferencia
de otros futbolistas se dedicó a dar el
buen mensaje de lo importante que es la
educación en los niños y todas estas
cosas